[Music]
great starts
i mean you're gonna say that
well we can leave that in i wonder if a
podcast has ever started that way it's
just a cough i'm sure we see there's
probably a podcast that exists that's
just all about coughs no there are so
many podcasts i know that is true um
cough cast
that's kind of a good idea different
or different involuntary reactions not a
good idea you don't think of fart cast
just i listened to a podcast all about
fun you're getting warmer uh
so to speak
um is it fart warmer than a cough you
think
probably probably the same temperature
because it comes but i would say a fart
might be probably both 98.6 degrees i
think a farm might be warmer only
because it's been in your body long like
a cough is just like
well it's no there's no way to it still
comes from your body who cares how long
it's been in there that's true oh man i
feel dumb but isn't it funny like of all
this stuff i want to cut so far that's
that that would be top of the list and
not the
involuntary cough at the beginning
anyway why should we just start the show
i think yeah well that's uh downstroke
that's an intro i like that story well
should i just do the quick version of
the what we were going to say sure um
last night i
ate too many chess men that was it all
right here's the show
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i am
your slightly coffee host justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
and with me as always is my bearded
brother he's not always bearded
christian but he's choking it now you
know you say coffee host and you're
drinking coffee oh weird double coffee
oh that's strange i didn't mean to do
that what's that called what is that
grammatical phenomena called uh an
oopsie oh yeah
from shakespeare's
term i think marlow i think yeah anyway
speaking of chess men that you indulged
in last night i did well i have god you
you are a maniac with those things i
have a real problem and i threw the bag
at christian at one point because i
needed him to keep them away from me i
can't stop eating them you're like
you're like a junkie i eat them like
chips you're like a junk food junkie
that's i was eating popcorn earlier and
i was popping them as quickly as i was
popping the chest yeah you eat chess men
like potato chips i don't know how you
do it i don't know how you're what 150
pounds well i've been going to the gym
doesn't matter no i know i i have a i
guess i have a fast metabolism but i
know it's going to catch up to me so i
have to like i'm worried when i have
those those where i just pull the rip
cord you might just wake up one day and
be fast
you know you might be one of those like
everything just like falls apart um why
are we talking about well my favorite
pepperidge farm yeah you didn't ask me
no i was about to i'm gonna volunteer it
too is uh mint milanos i like mint
milanos a lot they're my favorite type
of they're my favorite flavor milano the
flakiness yeah it i think i think
they're perfect they're satisfying and
there's just enough chocolate to get a
little bit of that and there's it's
the raspberry milanos are good too but
and the orange
mint is the best i saw uh some wild
milano flame flavors recently that it
was like i know there's double fudge
right
and there's also a player on the buffalo
bills called matt milano which always
confuses me and i wonder it sounds like
mitt milano yeah i wonder if matt
milano's listening i wonder if he i
always wondered this when i watch him
play if he how often he or if he ever
gets people calling mint milano there's
another milano you know there sure is
our very special guest today is named
milano the star of iconic tv show who's
the boss
the milano that we're referring to is
alyssa alyssa milano alyssa is uh we've
known her since we were kids not
personally but um of course we grew up
watching who's the boss there's a time
for love and a time for loving living
living the rest is up to you my friend
uh do you know the rest and
interestingly enough you are the one who
sang that theme song for for the show
yeah people might not know that when i
was when i was five also that show took
place in our hometown of fairfield
connecticut and i thought that was so
cool you both have to think in school
that is the fictional setting for who's
the boss was your hometown i i did too i
love that show
yeah grew up watching that show i i you
know i associated how good was she oh
judith tony danza it's an amazing show
it's an amazing show you sound a little
too much like joey uh a little joey
lawrence
whoa
uh mona whoa that show you know i
associate it with
being homesick from school because
whenever i was homesick from school i
would watch yes every single time i'd
watch that show so it and it gave me
like uh you know when you're feeling
shitty
that you yeah it's like it gave me
brought me comfort yeah yeah it was a
real comfort show you don't both have to
be comforted by who's the boss when
you're homesick from school and of
course she's gone on to do so many other
things you know she was uncharmed yes
that was a show that
i i didn't get into when it was on i
didn't know when it was on but it is on
all the time
like charm just one of the shows that
like any time of the day you can watch
it and now she is uh i would say a
pretty major
activist yeah she's a player she's a
political sphere she's a political
player in in the um yeah in the world of
active a rather polarizing figure
i would say that's fair to say right
she's she's quite polarizing she is
polarizing she is a very um she very uh
opinionated and she speaks her mind she
sure does and she often does on uh what
she does on twitter and instagram and
she but i think she like shows up at
those marches and stuff and really like
talks
walks walks the talk walks the talk
walks the walk this is the first time
i've ever gotten to really sit down and
have a stay
let's get to know her better here we go
the
charming and charmed alyssa milano life
could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again shaboom and over we'll
meet again
[Music]
hey listen do you miss the seasons do
you miss uh living in allied do you miss
the east coast
i mean
with climate change we're now starting
to get some seasons here we had a
thunderstorm the other day and yeah was
my kids basically their first thunder
ten and seven and then the dog the dogs
were going nuts and i have horses on the
property and they were all
like freaking out like what is this
and of course all of my friends are
texting me like oh isn't it so
you know just so cozy and romantic and
like in my head i'm going no this is
it's the end of the earth yeah what did
your kids think it's like um
what was it like to for to experience
lightning for the first time through
their eyes that's so wild they're like
oh that's lightning right because as a
child the imagery of a light lightning
bolt
is you know obviously part of their
world yeah well the chargers now they're
in la they're probably right the
chargers we have we have tickets so for
them to to see like oh that's what all
of us is about is that yeah it was it's
really interesting did they think it was
cool were they into it yeah for sure
does it ever strike you like how
different their
lives are from the one that you had like
from from your own upbringing well yeah
for
numerous reasons yeah yeah
you know i joke about all the time that
i have peter pan syndrome because i i
didn't have a normal childhood so
i am definitely living vicariously
through
um them we just went toward a middle
school because it's i i don't know how
it's that time
um but it's that time for milo you know
he's in fourth grade which i can't i
don't even understand but i'm literally
walking around this middle school just
like
almost feeling a tinge of jealousy that
these kids are having such
nor even with the masks and everything
it still feels more normal than what my
experience is like because how old were
you alissa when you started
i was my daughter's age i was seven
years old when i did the play annie was
it your doing were you like i'd love it
was it just simple as that for my sixth
birthday my aunt got me tickets to go
see the play annie and i looked at her
and my parents after that and i said i
could do that
and
a year later i was in the second
national touring company
oh my god
do you remember that moment i mean do
you remember seeing it and thinking that
i remember things like vague
instances i remember
seeing kids singing and dancing on stage
and you know i was such a an artistic
kid that that just made sense to me
you know once i started working i
remember like this feeling that i got
from applause you know and and that it
was definitely lighting up some sort of
reward center yeah reward center in my
brain it's that guy you got a thousand
likes at the same time so yeah and then
i got off the road and did some
off-broadway theater and then went for
an audition for a
show a pilot called you're the boss
you're the boss it was called you're the
yeah originally it was called you're the
boss and then i got who's the boss when
i was 10.
the first
first season when i was 11 and we went
until i was 19. well and weirdly i it
was it took place in fairfield
connecticut right that's right that's
where i am right now are you in
angela bauer's house kind of
hey mona um
i know i wish i although i remember
talking to tony danza about tony danza
was um
when i met him and i have such a bad
memory that i'm kind of forgetting the
circumstances but i remember my
grandmother and my mother were with me
and i i don't think i had ever seen them
both at the same time so charmed they
were so charmed by him i am he's a very
charming guy you know they don't make
him like that anymore he's right
he holds people's attention and is very
comfortable in that i feel like you know
actors now sort of you know are not
comfortable being the center of
attention
um or at least they like they feign like
they're not yeah we're like conditioned
to feel like we need to blend into the
walls um but he is very much a showman
and he does a one-man show and it's like
a
cabaret show and he sings and he dances
and were you aware of who he was and
like were you aware of what was your
relationship
like with fame or any kind of
and what and was he famous enough at the
time for you to even consider that in
your 10 year old brain yeah i think so i
mean i knew him as like the cute guy
from taxi
right like that's because taxi was huge
and catherine was on soap
and that was a huge show
so yeah i was aware of of that kind of
that kind of fame
um did it intimidate you i mean were you
like you you always struck me just
watching you growing up you always
struck me as having a real sense of like
confidence and self-assuredness yeah i
think that i i was always um very
comfortable in in who i was
yeah and really ground grounded which
makes my
adult
not groundedness
a little bit more ironic but yes i there
was that's true yeah there was something
very and maybe even stoic about me as a
child i wasn't going to allow many
people in i was an only child too until
i was uh my brother and i are 10 years
apart so that might that may have had
something to do with that yeah
my mother as well she's my uncle the two
of them are ten years apart and and she
always described it as being
a little bit less of a sister more of
like a like an aunt to him you know a
little bit more of a
she had enough authority and she never
felt threatened
by the attention he was getting
he was like my baby
yeah i mean that's that's how i i looked
at it and then when we were
i don't know when he was about 15 and we
started
you know reading
the same books and listening to the same
music that gap began to to shrink and
heat that's so nice he just uh had a
baby a couple of years ago and i can't
even i am so obsessed with my nephew
in a way that i just didn't expect i
mean i expected to love my nephew i love
yeah children in a way that you weren't
with your own children you can say it
yeah no that's true it's totally
different with my kids i hope milo's
listening to this one year uh poor milo
so then it became like when you're the
boss became who's the boss and who's the
boss became
this crazy thing
how drastically and how quickly did that
change your life well it felt really
slow because the first year of the show
we were on against family ties
and of course this was back in the day
when we only had three networks yes
and so
we came in
almost dead last in the nielsen ratings
every single week but abc believed
believed in us so much that they just
kept shifting shifting our time slot and
our night
and which would never happen now and
then we ended up
after this is how long ago this was
after happy days in the final happy days
oh my god i always forget happy days
bled into that
80s
like mid 80s that's crazy and then we
were a top 10
show for the you know remainder of
the seven years we were on the air oh my
god yeah we had a we had a rough a rough
start but i would say
it started getting
weird
for me just because i was not used to
not being able to go any place without
being recognized yeah when i was about i
would say
maybe about 13
and that was kind of my existence what
were the beginnings like what did it
feel like in the beginning with the
first few inklings that that might now
be your existence was it was it you
probably had no way of knowing that it
would be sustained but
was it cool in the beginning was there
an element of like oh cool no i was the
kind of kid that always wanted to try to
figure things out and i could never
figure out like why
right i was chosen to live this this
existence
it wasn't uncomfortable for me but it
was uncomfortable for my family
and i knew that them being uncomfortable
and feeling so protective of me in
public
made me
worry about them my bad
so where you know i think kids worry
about their parents
all the time that was my worry was like
oh i'm causing this there must be there
must have been a degree of shame
yeah exactly it was it wasn't shame it
was just like
responsibility
why me and a responsibility and and a
little bit of embarrassment so it wasn't
yeah
it wasn't shame it was embarrassment of
things like you know going through
puberty in front of all of america you
know and having people like dissect you
and when i started developing they would
they wrote it into the show i mean i got
a script on a friday night after a
taping called sam's first bra and i was
like um
you know i was
i was probably 11 or 12 at the time
i was mortified
i bet because you probably even hadn't
even had those conversations with
i mean that's such a
such a delicate time sort of vulnerable
thing to go through
yeah i didn't go to a regular school so
i think
had i gone to a regular school
i think a lot of it would have balanced
out but because i was tutored on the set
for nine months out of the year uh-huh
you know um there there was no real
balance and so were your parents in any
way
so they it doesn't sound like they
pushed you into it at all it sounds like
it was something you really wanted to do
yeah no end to the point where
my mom didn't even come to set with me
she hired a guardian because my brother
was so much younger
and it was
it was so important to my mom
to be also his mom
and to
you know have dinner on the table and
when i got home from work and
she would tell you you know her job was
to make sure my panties were clean not
to highlight my my lines
and so okay
and so
yeah and so she you know it wasn't it
was my life it wasn't their lives yeah
and did you have friends who were
outside that world outside show business
that you were able to kind of have a
more normal
um
you know friendship with not really i
mean my first real friend i was i was 19
and he's still my best friend oh how
nice
yeah but most of the time i i was just
around grown-ups
and
guy kids boys must have been weird with
you i mean i can only i can imagine they
must
it was awful
yes
it was yeah it was
traumatizing i bet and
how did your parents
protect you from that like what what was
their move
how did they shield you from that love
just love just love and like a constant
reminder of
you know the things that are important
in life i was other things beside an
actor or a child actor i was also a
sister and a daughter and a poet and a
an artist and
skateboarder whatever it whatever so
that didn't become your identity
exactly people know you now you are
doing something that is kind of
transcends acting and and you're doing
something you're really using your voice
and uh you've become a huge activist
and when did that begin because i i
remember seeing
donahue i remember seeing you and ryan
you kiss ryan white which was an amazing
thing that a lot of people may be
listening to this weren't aware of or
had forgotten about but that to me was
like
because we were similar age i remember
being really struck by
that and
the courage that that took to do that
and and the impact that that had was
that when it began would you say that's
when it began for sure yeah i mean
um
everything made sense
to me after that moment after that
that uh realizing what it meant to be
um in the public eye and all of the good
it could could do
in
complete i mean ryan was a hero he
completely
reshaped the narrative of hiv aids in a
time
when um
it was
it was there was a lot of stigma
attached
and our government sort of fed into our
biggest our biggest fears and and
worries
not much has changed in in that respect
but
but it it was a defining moment in my
life because um
i just felt like talk about your reward
center lighting up
yeah i felt like
this is why i get it now really fed you
i get it i get it now god from that
moment on i didn't
i don't know fame without activism you
know interesting yeah
seems like i'm a lot more active now
because
i get to control my platform with social
media
but back then i mean you know we had to
we had to wait for someone to want to do
an interview with us to share
who we were you know
how how did you come to meet ryan white
elton john
which just gives you a a little glimpse
into how
obscure my childhood was yeah well what
kid doesn't know elton john right but um
he so elton uh
you know who was such an advocate and
activist
for the lgbtq plus community then
uh just as he is now and
he
uh recognized that that ryan white
his story was different because
he uh contracted hiv from a blood
transfusion yeah and he was a kid and he
realized that that
ryan put a human element
uh that was lacking
um that led people to feel a certain
amount of empathy and compassion
um
and so
he and ryan became friends and
through that friendship elton learned of
ryan's love for me
and so he introduced me to ryan oh wow
and ryan and i became
very good friends and so asking me to
kiss him on the donahue show came from
from a a very
deep love for each other yeah i bet and
and a sense of responsibility that that
you've now really you know used to great
effect that you mentioned your platform
and being able to use that to affect
real change and that was huge i was huge
for
me i mean i was
i was being fed the same stuff that
everybody else was in terms of
the stigma surrounding aids and and um
that went a long way that was huge what
you did the thing that i think was
very different though about that time
was that we were encouraged to use
our fame for good
then um and and when you look at people
like
audrey hepburn when you look at people
like danny k
paul newman when you look at roberto
clemente you know like even athletes
jackie robinson there was a you know the
entire civil rights movement were
celebrities standing behind with their
fist in the air and and handing over
their platforms to people so i don't
think i think that people in our
entertainment industry i think i think
we were scared into believing that
half of the nation would not buy our
products or watch our tv shows if we had
an opinion about things and i think that
that may have been a very successful
strategy
by the republican party because they had
very few celebrity supporters because
you know after the civil rights movement
when the democrats realized that it was
unjust for them to try
to uh keep because originally it was
the democrats who um you know
tried to suppress the black vote
um
and so
yeah
and so once that had uh
had shifted i mean i think
we were really encouraged to to use our
voices and it wasn't until this like
big hollywood machine came in and you
know put the fear of
god into movie stars where you know they
were allowed to have a voice
right like you said it does go bad goes
back to charlie chaplin i mean like
charlie chaplin was literally run out of
america for um
for standing up to to the powers that be
um
is there more of an impetus to do
this kind of work now is there ever a
part of you that wants to redirect your
energy back into acting to to doing so
to acting again or is it are
you more fulfilled through this work
it's real hard
after you've had this experience and and
mind you i i don't just mean political
activism but i'm also an ambassador for
unicef i've traveled the world i've seen
uh some really really hard hard things
to see
and i've always been incredibly
boots on the ground
i lived in south africa for three months
in 2000 and i've been to angola africa
only
two years after the peace treaty was
signed for the longest civil war
in the history of the world
um india six months after the tsunami
i've been all over the middle east
visiting
troops i've been
in kosovo
um
so
i only say this because
um
once you've had these experiences
the entertainment industry becomes a
means to fund
right right active is my activism and
advocacy work i bet yeah because i have
a very heart and to also maintain a
certain level of fame because they sort
of feed each other yes i mean well but
like you said it's the stakes are so
much higher so clearly higher to have
done all of those things i can't imagine
how then fickle and superficial it must
seem to go back back to oh yeah you know
what part of my playing now and
right and hit this
tape mark and say words that that you
didn't write and yeah and they've
somehow figured out a way to take a lot
of the artistry out of acting i don't
know how they i don't know how they
pulled that off
[Music]
one of my favorite aspects of the
holiday season i love the sounds the
sights of course watching
the lights the christmas trees and but i
also love the smells of the season the
chestnuts roasting and the smell of pine
and i also now love my own smell not to
odor brag i owe it all to native natives
new seasonal scents are here and i
could not be more excited because i am a
loyal native user i've been looking for
a healthy natural deodorant ever since i
heard about how bad aluminum and
parabens and sulfates are for you but um
i was never able to find one that that
actually worked that made me smell
better and and
covered up body odor frankly and now i
have i'm so thankful to them native
they're the best they use natural
ingredients like coconut oil and shea
butter uh they never use aluminum
parabens or sulfates but like i said it
still keeps you smelling fresh all day i
don't know how they do it but i love the
smell and now i'm excited for these new
seasonal scents
candy cane sugar cookie which i'm afraid
to try because i might try to eat my own
armpits um and fresh mistletoe so keep
the scents of the season with you with
natives limited time holiday scented
deodorants go to nativedodeo.com
long or use promo code long at checkout
and get 20 off your first order that's
native
deo.com long or use promo code long at
checkout for 20 off your first order
i used to have quite a bit of trouble
sleeping and i know christian did too
he's not here but uh i can i can attest
to this um our sleep has improved and
it's improved thanks to three very
important letters c
b and a d
in this case i'm talking about plus cbd
it's a gummy it's a sleep gummy that's
formulated by a team of medical experts
and doctors they taste great they're
made of award-winning cbd combined with
melatonin magnolia bark lemon balm
um you can sleep better it really works
i mean i've tried a lot of things a lot
over the counter things that leave me
feeling kind of groggy and weird in the
morning i never feel that way i wake up
feeling refreshed ready to go four out
of five people say that they suffer from
poor sleep at least once a week i used
to be one of the four out of five and
now i'm in the minority i'm one of one
of five people who who sleep great
thanks in part to the plus cbd gummies
just got a plus cbd to
pluscbdoil.com and enter promo code long
for forty percent off your order forty
percent so it's easier to try it so
visit plus cbd oil.com and enter promo
code long for 40 off your order
hello
[Music]
you've had so much experience in network
tv uh
a lot of that has
felt a little bit more forced and less
natural to me
has your experience changed in terms of
how you see
acting uh how you see the scripts that
are coming have you fallen out of love
with it to some degree i don't know that
i was ever in love with it i think that
i was always
and i think that that enabled me to
reach a certain level of success
yes but here's my problem
okay and it my problem is this
i have fought
really hard to be this woman that i am
right now
and
it's through you know a lot of hard work
and therapy and self exploration and
reflection and really uncomfortable [ __ ]
it has become harder for me
to walk on a set
and not be me
and to dive into
my emotional
well
yeah to portray someone else
right right to dive into
you know like i just did a movie for
netflix that'll be released in or
dropped whatever they say on in january
and my sister
dropped yeah dropping you you made it
dropping yeah my sister uh dies on page
on page four and so
you know for two and a half months i'm
walking into work every day and to
having to tap into my own emotional well
um that i've worked really hard to heal
oh i see yeah huh and so now it's like
it's like um yeah you're just
scratching a scab constantly constantly
and that's what we we do as actors right
we
we go back to our own trauma to to be
able to
you know
project
emotion it has become harder and harder
for me to do the more healed healed i am
and some actors they find it therapeutic
for me it gives me anxiety huh oh
interesting it's probably in a weird way
making you better you know i mean
because when you do accept something
like that you have to really like you do
with your activism you have to commit i
mean if your sister dies on page four
unless it's a five-page script
which would be
hilarious um
you have to really make maintain that
level of commitment which is
yes but it's kind of like it's kind of
like childbirth where
you it's so excruciating but then
something happens
when you're you know when your kid's
like 18 months old where you kind of
forget about the hard
the the trauma of actually going through
it and you're like you know what i could
do that again i've always wondered that
listen because this similar thing i've
i've that's happened to people in my
life and i always wonder if that's just
like an evolutionary thing if that must
there must be some evolutionary
mechanism that it's the combination of
oh now it's an age where it's really
cute they're not constantly [ __ ]
themselves um and you you like you said
forget forget about
the struggle
the struggle yeah and that's kind of
like working on a on a
movie or a tv show for me oh okay so i
do know about childbirth yeah so i well
no no you said it you said that i know
exactly how childbirth feels um
well have you ever thought about then
getting like giving that up then and and
running for office i i wonder this about
you often like
because you are
i mean you are so good at what you do
um and it sounds to me like
you just enjoy it more on a very
purely superficial level so do you ever
think about just oh yes i'll run for
office yes it feels like that would be a
natural progression um
my
my thought though is i'm not sure i'd
get as much done
all of my friends who are in congress
whether they're in the house of
representatives whether they are in the
senate whether they are
state senate or
yeah or you know municipal whatever
whatever it is
yeah all your friends yeah my buddies
ted cruz ted cruz sure yeah you know all
my buds they um joe manchin they are all
very
uh
frustrated and a lot of them were
activists and community organizers
actually the most effective legislators
i know were activists and community
organizers but you
have to be okay with the incremental
wins
i don't know that you're ever
working to solving issues if you're an
elected official it's just pushing stuff
around it just seems like it's just
moving stuff
and it's also it's like making sure [ __ ]
doesn't get rolled back
yeah that the fights that were already
won how do you keep then my my question
now because how do you keep from being
too spread out i see i see you
everywhere i see you with voting rights
i see you with me too i see
you are active in so many areas of
activism
how do you do that without being
overwhelmed i guess
by all of the injustice i'm always
overwhelmed
okay so you do i'm not saying i'm not
saying i'm not overwhelmed i am
overwhelmed but i have a hard time
saying
no
yeah
and also i look at it as
a challenge to be able to educate and
empower myself to learn about all of
these different issues and the history
of them and be creative in my thinking
on how to
manage them in a different way or get
people looking at things in a different
light much like what ryan white was able
to do what was he like by the way like
what was he like as a person what are
your
memories of him he was courageous but
like hanging out like when you guys
would like be around each other he was
funny
he was funny he was self-deprecating
he was was he scared was he afraid he
never let on that he was afraid i'm sure
he was because by you know the end he
was very sick
uh and he had a fight to go back to
school and he spoke in front of congress
i mean this
the weight of the world it was spend
your last
amount of time with that kind of
scrutiny and pressure really amazing
what he went through there are people
like my friend adi barkin who has als
who is
i mean he is a civil rights attorney who
has
dedicated his last and final days in you
know medicare for all and getting
everyone
health care and he's just you know
they're there are really miraculous
incredible people and if they can keep
going
then i can keep going i'm yeah i might
be a little medicated but
yeah well whatever gets you through the
night
uh are you are your kids ever like
mom relax are they ever like
how do you how do you
filter this stuff because a lot of it is
[ __ ] it's a lot of it is overwhelming
and
deeply sad and how do you filter it um
so that they're not absorbing a lot of
that
you know what i don't really
have to filter it because they see it in
such a beautiful pure way
um
like for instance uh
when we were fighting for dreamers uh
daca in 2017 2016 or 2017 i told him i
was going on a bus tour and we were you
know i told them all about dreamers and
and how
our president was was trying to send
them back to countries that weren't
their homes and this was the only home
that they knew and in some instances
they didn't even you know know the
language of the countries that they were
being sent back
to and my son after this whole long day
of being on the bus
uh with dreamers i opened i opened the
door and he looked at me and he said
did you win mama do the dreamers get to
stay home and i was like
that's it
that's it if we could just
de-politicize every issue and bring it
down to its most fundamental right well
that's what i love about a group that i
know you're familiar with uh our friend
elsa this is about humanity um
that's what they do i mean that's at the
at the heart of their work is about it's
about people and that's what's been so
beneficial to me when i get to actually
see the people that are benefiting from
what they're doing and the fundraising
because because some of these things
sometimes it can become like you know
this better than anyone it can just
become this abstract thing it must be
frustrating to you to do work for a
political to
help promote a political candidate uh to
do surrogate work and then
see them maintain this
really inhumane status quo do you have
access to these politicians are you able
to say to them
you know do you have the the direct line
do you have the bat phone where you can
say hey what the [ __ ]
i have connections with uh president
president biden
um i did i i had a bat phone during the
the campaign i do not have that bat
phone anymore
but um my activism
is critical of both sides of the aisle
and
i don't think just because a democrat is
our president
they should
be void of criticism when criticism is
um due and by the way it's the whole
democratic party right now is yeah is uh
disappointing many people um yeah and
and you know part of me feels like
everything that we sent them to do
joe biden had a very progressive uh
platform the most
progressive we had seen
from from a candidate um maybe not a
primary candidate but from a yeah
from a presidential candidate yes um and
he was very smart he borrowed from all
of the most
progressive candidates in the primary
and took ideas from everybody and
listened to organizations and listened
to grassroots organizations and listened
to activists and listened to advocates
and
um
you know we
we kept the house we flipped the
senate-ish
and we sent the president in record
numbers
to dc to fulfill a very progressive
agenda and it has been incredibly
frustrating
for uh
activists
everywhere
um
to not
now mind you if we can get build back
better
past
it is going to
change the lives of many american people
and at the end of the day i think that's
the most important thing
but there's a lot that i i'm
disappointed in thus far
do you ever um you had mentioned the
dangers of social media and um
how it can be overwhelming do do you
ever take breaks do you ever and and if
so
how does that affect you i mean how are
you affected by
um staying off social media for a length
of time
i'm fine with it actually there's
there's it it seems like i'm on social
media all the time but i am uh really
good at um
like composing tweets or making tick
tocks weeks in advance and then just
dropping something
um
you have a time for it you you yes
yeah
yes yes you have to and um you know i i
paint and i am a gardener and do all
sorts and i i love to read and so i do
all sorts of
um things to that that aren't
you know about
uh
activism and advocacy work
well my other questions are all about
gardening so perfect
bring it
um what is your prize what's what's the
thing that you brag most about your like
uh
your garden brag i have uh well i have
80 oak trees on my
property 80 yes and
we just um
lost one we had an arbiter come out and
it was it was uh it was whole holed out
in the middle and becoming dangerous so
they cut it they cut it out but they
left this beautiful
uh oak tree stump
um that i have started gardening in
oh wow yeah it must be so fertile
because it's like rotten
but it looks so beautiful and it's like
it's so possible yeah it's really cool
so that's that's my little project right
now but i
i make terrainiums and do all sorts of
like
do all sorts of things like nerdy things
i got so into it during the quarantine i
that's all i kind of started doing on
instagram in fact was showing off the uh
my produce that i was growing
japanese egg plants i got really into um
i i feel you it's it it's it's actually
when i feel my most relaxed i think me
too it's my happy place
your book uh you have a gardening book
in fact called sorry not sorry it's all
about regarding gardening
um nobody but it contains 32 essays
describing your activism uh thoughts on
current issues why did you name it why
sorry not sorry i think i know but i'm
curious well the subtitle was going to
be
stories of being unapologetically [ __ ]
up
uh-huh
why [ __ ] that why would you say if
somebody said
okay so i've never heard of you i let's
decide an alien comes down from the
planet has never seen who's the boss
only saw the pilot when he's you're the
boss
and um and they say well
why why are you [ __ ] up why would you
say you're [ __ ] up that's a lot to
unpack that question there's a lot of
there's a lot of trauma there's a lot of
feelings
uh-huh you know so i mean you're [ __ ]
up in this but in
in the context of the title [ __ ] up
refers to
everything at all
everything dysfunction yeah listen this
is who i am these are my opinions
sorry not sorry okay i'm apologizing for
not being sorry
okay okay
are there times where you do feel like
oh [ __ ] i messed up have you ever felt
like oh i may have gotten this wrong and
i do now have to say i'm sorry oh yeah
and i'm sorry but like for sure for sure
but i think
the blessing is is that i get to
[ __ ] up in a really public way
and deal with it with as much grace as
possible
and promise to [ __ ] up less the next
time
and hopefully that makes the idea of
taking the fear away from people
withholding their empathy
yeah you know if they can say oh look
she said the wrong thing doesn't mean
our hearts in the wrong place and she's
dealing with it with grace and she
apologized
um and so i feel really blessed that i
get to do that publicly i mean you gotta
you gotta you gotta remove the ego from
the work but i don't think the ego can
be married to
activism anyway well otherwise there's
no room for discourse or for being wrong
or for
seeing things another way also you
you're attached to an outcome
and with activism
the only thing that you can do is plant
a seed yeah i look at people like alice
paul who wrote the equal rights
amendment which is my tombstone issue
and
she never got to see the
all 38 states ratify
you know the bill that she wrote the
amendment for the constitution that she
wrote
in 1920 but it might pass in my lifetime
so
if we're talking about gardening which
is what my book is all about you have to
be okay with with planting the seed
and allowing someone else to harvest the
fruit what do you do when it becomes too
much do you detach ever from it do you
unplug how do you clear your mind
take a gummy and have a margarita okay i
thought you said i'll take a gun a gun a
gummy a gummy yes a a weed gummy and a
margarita five milligrams what's your 10
milligrams
10 10 milligrams and i'll just uh
paint or
play in the dirt or or whatever
that's the best god bless marijuana do
you ever watch um
do you ever watch like trashy tv or do
you have a guilty tv pleasure i mean i
don't spend a lot of time in front of
the television which is so ironic
yes it is
what do your kids think of your stuff i
mean
i'm sure charmed comes on or who's the
boss i'm sure something you're on comes
on it somehow of the day they have no
desire to that my son is really really
my son really likes looking at my tick
tocks because he thinks i'm really funny
but as far as
as far i tried to get them to watch
who's the boss they were so
they're like okay mama look at you you
look just like bella and that's my
daughter and then they
you know ran off to play soccer or
something
no kidding we have the same chapstick uh
flavor i don't have it on me which i
wish i did cherry chapstick the best
um
that's so funny so they have no real
interest in
funny
and i would and i would actually say
that they're more interested in in my
activism than they are my acting oh my
gosh well so dave your husband i mean
like you must be around a lot of actors
that they recognize are there are there
ever people that they get excited about
like like superhero people
this is a sweet story my my son was
really inspired by amanda gorman's as we
all were a poem at the inauguration
and um
he decided that he was going to write a
poem
and so i sent it to her and she posted
it on her social media she pawned it off
as her own work no
no no i'm curious
oh my god could you imagine well this is
a scoop no
[Laughter]
no no we're cutting out all the parts
where you say no
no she she posted it and said this is uh
my nine-year-old friend milo wrote this
and so he he thought he was a big shot
from that
and i just thought that that was really
special um
you know nice thing to be celebrated for
too we call uh yes exactly we call um
bradley cooper in this house his uncle
bradley
um
but they don't know bradley
i can only imagine bradley around them
because bradley's he's so good at like
making you feel special and you know man
you look so good i can imagine he's very
charming with the kids he's very sweet
with them and
um he never forgets uh one of their you
know with their birthdays or oh that's
really sweet he sends me and my husband
anniversary gifts every single year
really for our wedding
are you serious yeah well he spoke at
our wedding 13 years ago or whatever and
you know he's been through all of his
friends being
with people and divorced and and
we are still going so i think he's just
he's really overwhelmed uh by that
it's a rare thing
it is
in our business yeah it is wow yeah so
yeah uncle bradley um
my son wrote a letter to governor
desantis about um
the wild cougar crossing that was
happening in uh in florida the animal
yeah
that that um
my son was very upset with and i
i recorded him
reading it and then i sent it to mark
ruffalo
and i was like
so you know you can totally say no to
this but it sure would mean a lot and if
you could give him a little
encouragement
um and so mark sent him a video and
milo was like oh cool i don't know
that's
well maybe he well he wasn't he hadn't
hulked out you don't want to get one
from bruce banner it's not as fun life
could be a dream
[Music]
hey life assured listeners business wars
is a podcast from wondering that brings
you the full stories behind some of the
biggest business battles in history in
their new season you'll hear about the
fight between espn vs fox sports to
dominate the sports television industry
espn is the american cable network that
blaze the trail for around the clock
sports coverage athletes even change the
way they play just to get on
sportscenter's nightly highlight reels
but right around the corner rupert
murdoch's fox sports channel started
gaining on espn in the us the sports tv
business is worth more than 12 billion
dollars the question is who will come
out on top fox sports or espn listen to
business wars espn vs fox sports on
apple podcast amazon music or you can
listen one week early and add free by
joining wondering plus in the wondery
app hey life is short listeners wonder
is even the rich podcast is doing a
two-part series on the bizarre and
fascinating kidnapping of paddy hurst
and you won't want to miss it
one night in 1974 19 year old college
student patty hearst who happened to be
the heir to the hearst newspaper fortune
was kidnapped from her berkeley
apartment she was kept in a closet for
weeks while her captors made their
demands then after two months in
captivity and a completely unexpected
twist paddy announced that her name was
tanya and was seen on video robbing a
bank with her captors the new season of
even the rich explores different
theories about what actually happened to
patti was she brainwashed or was she the
victim of stockholm syndrome listen to
even the rich on apple podcasts amazon
music or you can listen one week early
and add free by joining wondering plus
in the wondery app
hello hello again
[Music]
we have a lightning round
um
indulge me
okay
here we go
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say your go-to emoji the winky
kiss winky uh
winky and kissing with a little heart
coming in yeah okay uh yes i love that
one if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play you're
wearing a dodgers shirt i need to point
out to everyone yes i would be a
professional baseball player i would be
a catcher
a catcher yeah now why a catcher because
they control the entire game from back
then yeah that's true
you'd have to get hit a lot potentially
and also they're involved in every
single play right every every pitch
every single it's true so i mean i
couldn't be an outfielder because i'd be
like looking at the sod
you know see you know what's funny well
this is how different we are this
actually is like a perfect example of
like
how i have such fear whereas you are
there's a there's a courageous that's a
courageous answer because i don't know
if i'd be able to deal with that
pressure i in fact i remember playing
baseball and playing both positions and
not dealing with with the pressure
because outfield is like every once in a
while ball comes to you but if you mess
up that's even more pressure exactly the
outfield yes as a catcher being involved
in every single play
keeps your mind
in the game and focus so that that's
true you know one one past ball isn't as
monumental as you know if if you make an
error an error in the outfield and it
you know makes a
stretches a single in into a triple oh
it's humiliating yeah i feel like you
guys go to games a lot we do but we
we're we're a very sporty family you are
who's your football team
uh the new york giants because
david's father is the head of the chain
gang at 85 years old he runs out there
with the yardstick what and measures the
yardage
for the new york giants
mm-hmm
he's still doing it at 85. still doing
it holy god he's still coaching
soccer he just had his
899th
win as a high school soccer coach
in new jersey what he's in the soccer
hall of fame my father-in-law besides
just being
just an incredible
incredible human but he's just oh my god
uh if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life what would it be
cheez-its cheez-its
great oh my god i love cheez-its so much
yeah you didn't that was so quick you
had that
you it was so accessible
jesus
yeah they're delicious the good
old-fashioned kind in the in the red box
not the crisps
not the like ranch fake flavor the
cheddar oh yeah i know they're getting
crazy yeah would that mean that you you
also really like goldfish other kind of
like cheesy type snacks like
cheese based snacks no i don't think
anything compares to a cheez-it oh wow
really you're a real purist yeah um
what was your uh what was the movie that
you really we talked about like your
kids watching your stuff and being very
ambivalent about it but was there a
movie that you were excited like when
you had kids like you were really
excited to show them like that was maybe
something that was important to you when
you were a kid
i was really excited to show bella the
wizard of wizard of oz
and
she was really into it my son i'm still
waiting
i i want to show milo um searching for
bob bobby fisher and oh really um the
goonies oh i can't wait to show him yes
the goonies i get why searching for
bobby is he into chess because i think
that it is a universal theme for
children who are overachievers and
parents who
push their children
maybe a little too hard oh interesting
um and i just think i just think he'll
really enjoy it um have you ever done it
that bell is too young for this but have
you ever done the wizard of oz where you
sync it up the dark side of the moon
no but when you're on a gummy i
i know i know i've done it i've done it
oh you have i've done it for me yeah i
haven't done it it's wild right it's
it's wild but here's the thing is
i think everything has a rhythm to it
yeah maybe maybe so
and i think sometimes that rhythm
synchronizes to something else to
another rhythm
and when those moments you know like
when you're in the car and you have the
windshield wipers going and all of a
sudden they just
sync up to like the don't walk sign
flash yes totally
or a song that's playing even
all at the same time everything is
working together so i think it's in
harmony yeah i think there's a rhythm to
everything uh huh well you must see that
too because you live among nature it
sounds like you live there there's a lot
of
nature where you live so you must but
also like writing too you know writing
yes
there's a lot of uh rhythm
in being able to compose a sentence
impactfully i think you are
correct
sorry i was trying to do one without
rhythm um
what is your what's your go-to karaoke
song you're out singing you're adding
monkey
i can't if you're at a jukebox what
beatles song would you like to hear
right now
blackbird
yes god who was your first celebrity
crush
um so see thomas howell oh um but then
there was someone else that i thought of
the other day and i can't remember who
that person was now but yeah see thomas
howell
like in the outsiders
yeah right yeah ponyboy
is it
how
what you must and dave must have this
experience where people say that to you
all the time oh my god you were my crush
as a kid like people at parties must say
that to you all the time
has that gotten any
is that it must just be a part of your
life how do you how do you what does
that do to you how do you feel about
that
i always
am worried that
meeting me in person is somehow a
disappointment from whatever from
whatever the fantasy that they have
right that they have like
you know created of me in their own head
that yeah you know
i i have this this clothing line where
it's all sports licensed and um we do
signings a lot at stadiums and i always
i get these these sports fans that are
like oh my god you know you were my
first crush and whatever and i'm always
like oh my god and that's when i was
like in my prime at 18 and now i'm
almost 50.
and this [ __ ] guy is looking at me
this close
oh that's weird and i must be like and
i'll say i hope i'm not disappointing
you
oh man
that's
so strange yeah i know i also started at
a certain point like gauging my own age
when adults
would come up to me and i didn't start
that young
and they'd be like i watched you growing
up and like growing up you have a full
beard
wait but i didn't realize that i was
aging until like everybody else my age
looks old well you mentioned your peter
pan complex yeah i mean i uh there's
also some botox involved in that but
well that makes it easier to not
recognize aging
yeah i was gonna say you don't look like
you've aged
but i i keep looking at it but it's not
even like how i feel like i look it's
just
a recognition of
being middle-aged by seeing how other
people
are middle-aged if you had to get a
tattoo
oh you have tattoos but if if you do
have tattoos if you got another one what
would you get
uh probably my kids names uh-huh my lone
pillar great names by the way
um
what is your favorite fruit apple a fuji
an apple who is your favorite muppet
growing up animal of course of course um
he made me laugh he still makes me laugh
did you ever get to do a thing on sesame
street i never got to do anything on
sesame street i would love to do that uh
yeah what is your go-to pizza topping
just cheese i'm a i'm a
real originalist uh okay uh dogs or cats
dogs do you have dogs i have five dogs
oh wow okay all of them five dogs nine
horses eight chickens two bunnies you
have two bunnies i do
i um
that's good that's cool that's something
i rescued two bunnies yeah i i again
like i don't know how you do all of it
but i'm glad you do me too i mean these
are these are the things that make me
feel like a you know a human well good
well you are a very impressive human i'm
so glad i got to do this with you it's
really cool to get to talk to you thank
you i really appreciate your support
thank you so much
[Music]
so so that happened that just happened
uh a very um
very recognizable voice that was
what i was like i took my foot off the
gas and didn't commit so so that just
happened it's hard for me to do you're
doing like are you doing a little s
seductive
sounding yeah it sounds a little
seductive yeah well i was thinking could
that be
may i posit this theory yeah so that in
your brain
alyssa milano is associated with
your youth
and maybe having a crush on her no so
you
there's a part of you that still thinks
of her as
seductive
so when you do an impression of her
maybe it comes across a little seductive
that's true but um
i'm afraid of you thought policing my uh
intentions it's just a theory yeah it i
i don't want to say whether it's true or
not but i think it might be true well
you did have a crush on her yeah i said
that did i say that too no but i'm
assuming yeah you're that age you had a
you had crushes on a lot of pretty girls
every every
i think everyone did
listen milano was you know that we talk
about that in the show yeah a lot of
guests of this show you want to say it
to her because she's heard it has just
heard it and like there's so many guests
of that didn't joe gatto say that she
was yes without think without there's a
lot of people a lot of people she's the
first crush i know and i i also know how
to say that it's a little
i felt um
i didn't want to sound you know just
offensive or productive reductive yeah
in any way
sexist i was i was pretty cautious
talking to her about those things yeah
that i get that yeah so alyssa milano
grew up
on that show 11 tonight i didn't realize
it spanned her those ages i know 11 and
19. that's crazy and they wrote it into
the show how like yeah
her developing like
sam's first bra that was it episode i
can't remember that you do yes i do i
mean remember that
i i because i did watch that show a lot
i mean it was a long time ago my memory
is poor but i do whenever they revolved
around sam i
paid more attention probably
it's interesting though that what that
must have done it's like a lot of
development to be
so exposed i never thought about it of
course well i mean how could you have
and and especially after talking to fred
savage who had like the more idyllic
version of that i noticed you kind of
poking around trying to um
draw a parallel yeah like that you asked
if she had friends
outside of show business that like kind
of kept her grounded normal like he did
yeah and she didn't yeah you know like
she was friends she was so uh
ingratiated in that world that she would
only hung out with adults yes which i
wonder and it makes sense that she now
has
a certain amount of
jealousy i guess i mean she used that
word so i'm using it
um
towards her own children that normally
they have this normal i know and that
she would go to those lengths to protect
them and she talked about
you know keep having a little chickens
and stuff didn't she talk about that
like her um
you know how she's protecting them and
like
trying to enable them to have like a
more
kind of then also having uncle bradley
cooper and mark ruffalo be such an
active part of their lives true that
doesn't uh i mean what a charmer bradley
cooper oh man you know we don't we've
talked about of course i mean does it
surprise you at all that he remembers
their anniversary
i knew you know i said all the kids
birthdays
doesn't surprise me a bit bradley is i
mean i would say we've met a lot of
charming people in this business i don't
think i've ever i don't think i will
ever meet a more
fully charming person neil patrick
harris is quite charming of course i've
met a lot of other charming i mean kobe
smaller like there's some charming i've
met other charming people yeah but
bradley cooper is like
charm on steroids you know we got to get
bradley
on the show guess what if he said no he
would say it in the kind of yeah yeah
most wonderful way there was a rumor
that um about us last summer was it that
bradley was
here in our hometown we had moved to
fairfield connecticut yeah that's right
someone started that rumor it's not true
uh well
it turned out yeah he said he said it
was so i reached out to him and i said
um hey rumors you've moved into and it
was like the hot gossip oh my god
everyone was talking about it pretty
it's just small it's not that small it's
not so it's like 60 70 000 people yeah
everyone it was like these stories yeah
the rumor mill was a buzz uh of bradley
cooper's sightings and they saw him here
and he was there with leo and they're
all these uh and so i texted him and he
was like no
hey buddy he's like but how are you you
know like so charming and
and uh
and then people continue to see him and
so there was a brief period where i
thought
is bradley lying to me like was did does
he doesn't want you to think he's in
town
[Music]
he's so
insulting and then i thought like well
why would he just
he just wouldn't have written back if he
didn't want to see me right well maybe
not maybe he's so charming he wanted to
make you feel good yeah but he didn't
want to have to see you
that would check out but i don't think
he would do uh no i don't either but um
anyway he is we gotta get him on the
show that would be maybe
yeah yeah that would be that would be
again
and you know who else does it get alyssa
milano yes and we got her and man was it
what do you mean we got her i mean we
got her to be on the show oh yeah yeah
we invited her and she accepted why'd
you get so nervous just now i'm nervous
about words sometimes with some people
she
like you said she has quite a platform
and she is not afraid to
speak her mind no she's not and you know
it's interesting i thought that um when
she was talking about ryan white and and
that whole story i thought
god it's really wonderful what she did
and that's an example of something that
should be apolitical obviously it's like
i know
that story i know should should inspire
warmth and sympathy
and love in all people regardless of
your political ideology but then
she started talking about um
democrats versus republicans and like
like they're the bad guys and i mean she
didn't use those words exactly but but
that's the idea and i'm not putting it
on her i feel like generally that's
become the problem that you've taken
such sides i know it's not about it's
not really about the issues anymore it's
i know what side are you on yes and if
you're on this side it means that you
think everyone on that side is bad and
evil and if you're on that side you
think everyone on this side is bad so i
think like
the ryan white thing really um sparked
that idea in me that
people should if everyone like
recognized that we all want to get to
the same place but have different
mechanisms at like how we get there
um i feel like we would get so much more
done i know in the politically country i
know but if if it's you if you have a
name if you have a a d or an r next to
your name it it it's it means everything
it trumps any everything any idea you
know it doesn't mean that there aren't
like
tons of like extreme
[ __ ] bad people
on in both parties of course but
i think there i hope i think there are
more people who
want
good things for this country but just
have very different approaches of how we
get there uh that's well said i know i
wish um i don't know what the
prescription is i i do think that i i
really think the continuation of this
uh
vilification of one side or the other
vilification
continuation um i think it's i think
it's just fomenting those that sense of
tribalism and that divisiveness it's
it's um
it's such a shame but like
you know and i and i i it was difficult
to talk to her a little bit about that
because
i know that she is very outspoken and
does really take stands on on things and
you know i think in order to do in order
to make change happen you have to do
that i mean you have to
be that outspoken and but i just think
it's different now and it's not her
fault it's like we live in this social
media world where everyone is trying to
find the next like thing to jump on top
of yeah
good and bad but like back in the day
she mentioned people like audrey hepburn
and roberto clemente and paul newman
certainly i know because people were
they were like such forces for good and
i'm not saying that she's not but there
was something more neutral about
how they were seen i think you know paul
newman
look at what he did he like helped kids
right and
republicans and democrats and everything
in between
everyone's going to agree that that's a
good thing i know he did it it's such an
apolitical right movement you know
whereas
i think some of the issues that elicit
takes up are
quite politicized and i think that's why
she i think that's why she's very
uh courageous to do that very crazy
because she risks alienating all of
these you know a huge portion of a fan
base and that's ballsy and she doesn't
care she doesn't because she is she's
convicted and what she believes in yeah
but like you said the flip side is
you know continuing to
foment that
divisiveness right um
i don't know i don't know how i i
certainly couldn't do that so i
there's a part of me that it admires
that um because it's it's i don't have
i have convictions but i don't have the
courage to i don't have such strong
convictions that i would risk i mean we
both get scared about oh words we say i
know podcasts i know at one point she
was talking about her kid writing the
governor of florida a letter uh-huh
about oh yes wild cougar crossing yeah
and you just
well because you know
what uh it's not the best environment
for
jokes like that no so i yeah
but there was a part of me that like i
realized it was just i i needed to say
it i needed it it was like
too much to contain i know that loading
is loading from the lid on that pot
it was it was low-hanging fruit easy
let's read a letter okay
here we go from katie crouch
crouch crouch
it's a polish i think wait say it again
spell it again rather um k-a-t-i-e
second name
k-r-a-w c-y
i'm sorry k-r-a-w c-z-y-k
crotchet crotchet yeah i think you're
right krachik it's polish i think yeah
you don't both have to assume that the
name crouching is polish
um subject ciao
whoa maybe she's italian wow okay
uh ciao i mean but you know what i in
those out because i as i've discussed
spent a lot of time in some of those
eastern european countries and uh they
often many of them use ciao ciao is like
a
in bulgaria they use it uh estonia
anyway hello justin christian and life
is short crew my name is katie and i'd
first put it on record that contrary to
what you might assume from my subject
line i'm not italian oh
okay and that's the end of the letter
shut up
um however after listening to the
stanley tucci episode i became motivated
to learn how to speak italian i don't
have any that's i would that's a cool
language i would love to be able to say
because i think it fits the way i speak
anyway i think i speak with you know um
well you're live you do you know what
i'm going to say uh i don't know how to
say this now i know what you're trying
to say yeah that i speak in a kind of
flowery way well which brings us back to
the beginning that i have some if
some of those qualities might be
considered
feminine i think flowery and effeminate
are two pretty different things that's
true because
that's stanley tucci is by no means he
speaks in a italian kind of yeah but not
like a stereotypical like hey that this
simpsons
italian chef character or like chico
marx right um
okay back to kate however that she's
gonna learn italian let's go i don't
have any big plans to go there anytime
soon but the fantasy of driving through
the italian countryside eating amazing
food and admiring the culture is what's
keeping me going i totally agree with
her i i want to do that so badly and
both from stanley's show and also from
um i love that movie uh steve coogan
movie with rob um yes uh what's the
trip the truth the yeah the italian trip
no no that's the mark wahlberg there's
two or three of them yeah yeah where
they go on a trip in india those are
great i can't believe i can't think
they're so funny one is just called the
trip i think you're right um
they're great anywho of this funny i was
going to say that and katie says that in
her letter any who
she says in justin's voice well in fact
jerry's yeah you incorrectly attribute
that to me the best best friend of the
show jerry o'connell
lis
uh jerry oc
uh i have a two hour round trip to and
from work so i've decided to split my
time between learning italian by an
italian for beginners podcast on the
drive to work and then i listened to
your podcast on the way home that is
such a good idea i i sorry i keep
interrupting but um
i'm really inspired by this letter so
far because i want to do that and i
spanish is not sticking
i need to find a different that's an
understatement
so far it's been a great balance and
makes the drives less painful about two
hour round trip i wonder where she works
uh i'm such a fan of the podcast and a
huge accepted fan but because of that
movie i have beef with you justin what
do you think her beef is going to be
oh
god i don't know
here we go let's find out i watched it
with my older sister when it was first
released and afterwards i learned the
hard way that [ __ ] is a bad word
not to point fingers but i think we all
know who's to blame for the trouble i
got in with my parents for being a potty
mouth at the ripe age of 10.
wait wait wait wait a minute she didn't
know
at 10 that [ __ ] was a bad word i guess
not
so it's
you know what's funny i often say i i
was pretty young
um 10 is young but trying to remember i
i was a late bloomer when it came to
that stuff and i
i definitely knew about [ __ ] when i was
third that's third grade cool
you want a parade i think not everyone
does
i guess so yeah um i was driving in uh
la traffic and i was like oh man and i
pulled up next to um this car and i was
the the back window was down a little
bit and there was this adorable dog i
was on sunset in highland you know how
it gets really crowded there i was i was
at that light by that in and out and um
there was a really cute dog i was just
staring at the dog i was like kind of
like out of it i've been in traffic and
i was just like tearing the stock and
the
in the driver's side window the
passenger side just went
like rolled down and these two people
were like staring at me and i looked at
and i go oh sorry
sorry i was like checking out your dog
and um
and there was a woman in the front seat
and i think the guy at first i thought
the guy thought i was like checking out
like staring at his
you know
partner
and um the guy goes yeah i go sorry i
was just looking at that you're talking
he goes nah man i'm a [ __ ]
that's funny yeah and he was like a big
accepted fan anyway um
uh it's back to katie yeah assumes you
feel bad and apologize here oh she
assumed i would feel bad i i don't feel
bad um
because you didn't write it i didn't
write it and um
if you're a 10 it is like a pg-13 movie
you know if you if you didn't know the
word [ __ ] by the age of 10 i would
assume that your parents will be
watching
yes yeah and the thing with that movie
is i think we've talked about this it
should have been r then there was a cut
that is our where we jonah especially
like had a lot of r-rated ad-libs but in
a pg-13 movie i think you have a
limitless number of shits that you can
say but only one
maybe two [ __ ] and so no apology from
you none okay back to the letter
it's okay all is forgiven and i'll leave
the past in the past she assumes you
would have apologized she's being cheeky
since you so kindly apologized here is a
would you rather for you and christian
wow now i kind of feel bad i didn't
apologize
okay would you rather have the ability
to teleport once a day but never know
the location until you arrive or be able
to teleport wherever you wanted but
every time you arrive to a new place you
turn into a random animal
in each scenario you have to spend at
least 24 hours in the location you
teleport to okay so
you go with yourself so we're assuming
mammal
like animal like a mosquito is not an
animal
well it is it is it's just not it's true
it's part of the animal kingdom oh yeah
yeah i don't i don't think of bugs as
being animals well they are i guess they
are yeah insects um well
there's insect mammal reptile amphibian
my answer is my answer is this yeah
my answer is
i would rather go
as an animal
and control where i'm going as long as i
wasn't like a mosquito and someone could
crush me in the 24 hours if i was safe
any non-insect if i was safe and i could
keep a human brain yeah and i can see
that place through yeah for my current
yeah mental situation i would i think
i'd rather be an animal i would too
unless here's the problem if you were if
i popped up as like a jaguar or
something oh then you'd be you'd be and
then they try to and then i you couldn't
ensure your safety because yeah because
you wouldn't have that animal brain
you'd be like
you'd you everything would be a threat
because you'd have your brain but you'd
be out in the wild in a jaguar people
would all be looking at you and trying
to take you down
because you'd be a threat of course if
you so that's the caveat i would rather
be an animal as long as you could choose
your animal
no not just choose but as long as i was
an animal that didn't draw attention to
itself what animal would be and i remain
safe what animal would best exhibit
those qualities
a gnat a gnat yeah well that's like a
mosquito you say you don't want to be a
mosquito i'm not i would be a mosquito i
just don't want to be crushed oh i see
if i could ensure my safety i would
rather be something small and
low-profile i wouldn't i would prefer to
be something if i were to be a bird bird
would be curd i was going to say because
like then you could you could cover more
area and a mosquito just like they like
hover in the same cover more area every
day you get to
teleport somewhere else in the world of
your choosing how much area do you need
to cover on top well let's say you
teleport to
somewhere in like egypt egypt's a huge
country you'd want to make it to the the
pyramids you wouldn't want to spend i
mean like if you're somewhere in like
the desert you know and but you could go
to egypt every day for uh two months if
you want and then you could end up
seeing the whole my point is you have to
spend think about what you said you've
spent 24 hours in the location you
teleport to let's say you teleport to
someone in the gobi desert
why would you do that though
why would you oh
you can pick your place that's true
that's true okay i forgot about that um
also if you're a human if you're
teleporting as yourself into a random
location what if you go like into the
middle of like some war zone right you
know you're in the why would you pick
the war zone
well no no because you don't
you don't pick it exactly right exactly
yeah yeah you're right the first one
it's random you're right yeah i would
pick the second one if i want to have
control of where i'm going even though
there is something fun about popping up
somewhere it's it's also kind of scary
because what if not just scary but like
potentially kind of boring i think
there's more
things in this world that i don't want
to see that i do want to see wouldn't
you agree yeah
a lot i mean you think
i think so
i would say most places in this world i
wouldn't want to spend 24 hours in
oh really oh there's but there's
countless places that i would oh that's
true i mean you know most places are
quite desolate that's what i'm saying
yeah but it's like so beautiful
yeah but you don't you don't need 24
hours in siberia right you need like an
hour to poke around and be like whoa
this is desolate cool you should spend
an hour in siberia yeah
oh no i think you'd find that that's a
good name for a memoir for me an hour in
siberia i think
i don't want to assume but i think
i would guess that if you were in
siberia you just popped up there
teleported there that you'd want to
spend it would be like really
spectacular this the silence the the
like quality of the air the
the the majesty of the like expanse like
i'd have to figure out a place to sleep
well yeah oh i see what you're saying
i'm just saying the logistics of it yeah
make more sense if you're an animal yeah
that's true you know i just realized i
think i would be i would choose to be
like a pigeon or something because
because um
that's so funny imagining you as a pig
well because then i get i'd be i'd want
to be close to people i want to be able
to get close and pigeons have access to
like the human
human society in a way that most animals
don't you kind of have pigeon energy as
a person yeah like you're always poking
around poking around getting close to
things yeah i'm not i'd like to bop
around it's a good question though it's
a great question
keep thinking about that great katie
crotchik okay back to katie and now i
want to apologize for her i don't know
how what i could have done to control
her having seen that movie okay back to
katie thanks again for being the best
form of entertainment on my work
commutes and throughout my childhood
that is so nice sincerely katie thank
you katie grazie crotchet grazie for
tutti thank you yeah that was really
good uh thanks katie and we really
appreciate that's a really good letter
oh yeah really really good
rather good question and if you guys
would like to write in yourselves
we very much enjoy getting these letters
i think that's evident
i know i just wanted to make it very
clear abundantly clear how much we enjoy
reading these letters and even though we
only read one an episode but we love
reading them and
if you'd like to write in and write your
own letter our email address is life is
short at wondering.com
and thanks to our guest alyssa milano
our very special guest who has been a
very
very um
active present part of our lives since
we were little kids it was that was
pretty surreal it was cool to hear her
voice talk to you grew up watching her
and um it was nice to get to
actually get to know her so i hope you
enjoyed that as well now we need to get
tony downs on the show
yes and uh if you were going to write it
oh man that'd be great to get him on
yeah and danny pintaro yeah the whole
cast
um and if you are gonna write in as
christian mentioned uh maybe talk about
your favorite pepper's farm
cookie what pepper farm cookie do you
like oh an assignment yes yes i don't
know what a suggestion um and if you are
a representative from pep rage farm and
you want to advertise on our show
feel free because uh we're fans okay and
um thank you for for listening to
everyone and uh and hey happy holidays
yeah happy holidays we'll talk to you
next week bye
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
there's a time for love and a time for
leaving now's the time we say goodbye
you've been listening to life is short
no life is short is hosted by me justin
long and it's co-hosted by you christian
long it's also produced by you and
produced by megan v monaco and katy v
allen
senior producers michelle you're like i
see your brain working so hard to do
this that's sorry senior producers
michelle miesh lance audio engineer is
sergio enriquez executive producer is
marshall louie for a company called
commentary
monterey
bye everyone
[Music]
baseball managers come to talk to the
pitcher yes
there's always this this era of like
all right well you gotta go to bed right
now you know like when they like give
the things back like no you did okay you
like your toy back he's like you're
making me
like walk away
yeah
it's so shameful like a new like guy
comes and he's like okay i can do better
you